[Música]
Olá,
minhas amigas, meus amigos. Sejam muito
bem-vindos para uma live do grupo dois
estudos avançados. Eu tenho um material
muito bom para dividir com vocês hoje
aqui. Boa noite, Hélio Moraes. Boa
noite, Dra. Ana Paula.
Bem, eu já avisei aqui no grupo do
WhatsApp para quem se inscreveu no nível
dois. Espero que todos estejam cientes
já. Eu também fiz um post lá no YouTube.
Bem, como eu tenho muito material, acho
que eu não vou me delongar mais. Vou
começar aqui já.
Bem, primeiro assunto que eu quero falar
com vocês é muito muito interessante,
que é o assunto sobre os RCTs, que hoje
são considerados como o supraassumo da
produção científica
médica, né? Então, tudo que não é RCT,
randomiz control trials,
seria algo assim maravilhoso, o nível
mais elevado de ciência.
Mas o que eu vou te contar agora pode
mexer com tudo que te ensinaram sobre
ciência médica e não é teoria de
conspiração, é sobre como o sistema que
deveria nos curar está, na verdade, nos
mantendo doentes, tá? Então isso já
houve uma época que eu achei que isso aí
era a teoria da conspiração, mas não é o
caso.
Então aquele mantra que a gente escuta a
todo momento, especialmente quem é da
área de saúde, cadê o estudo
randomizado, cadê o RCT, né, que é um
termo inglês para
estudo randomizado pro cego, né? Aliás,
eh, estudo randomizado controlado, né?
RCT. Então, esse tal de estudo
randomizado, controlado virou
praticamente uma religião na medicina
moderna. Se não passou por um RCT, não
seria digno de nota, não prestaria. Se
não teria aquele valor, né, de
estatístico, para quem entende um
pouquinho de estatística, o p menor de
005, ele seria descartado como evidência
anedótica, ou seja, praticamente uma
conversa fiada, né? Mas aqui vai a
bomba. Esse padrão ouro da medicina tem
um problema gigantesco. Ele foi
desenhado para testar remédios isolados,
remédios farmaceuticos e não saúde de
verdade, não como seu corpo funciona.
Boa noite, Cristiana. Cristiana não,
Cristina Carol, seja muito bem-vinda
aqui à nossa live. Vocês vão ver que a
os próximos vídeos eu vou comentar, eu
vou mencionar os membros do nível dois
no final dos vídeos, tá? como maneira de
carinho, de agradecimento por vocês
estarem apoiando. Então, deixa eu te
explicar ou explicar para vocês uma
coisa que poucos médicos param para
pensar. Os tais dos RCTs, eles nasceram
lá pelos anos 1950. Eles foram criados
especificamente para avaliar remédios e
ambientes super controlados. Então, a
ideia era muito simples, era pegar uma
droga, um fármaco, isolar ele do demais
fatores confundidores,
testar contra o placebo que é pílula de
farinha, e controlar todas as variáveis.
Seria muito lindo no papel, mas tem um
detalhe crucial. A vida real não
funciona assim. O seu corpo não é uma
planilha do Excel, onde você pode isolar
variáveis e fingir que o resto não
existe. Então, vou te dar um exemplo bem
na cara. Tenta fazer um estudo duplo
cego com dieta acetogênica. Como é que
você vai esconder de alguém que ele tá
comendo gordura ao invés de carboidrato,
né? Fica impossível. Então não tem como
você fazer RCT para isso. Tenta fazer um
RCT com vitamina D. Quando a pessoa pode
sair na rua e produzir vitamina D só
disposição solar, tenta isolar o efeito
da vitamina C quando ela trabalha junto
em sinergia com a vitamina E, com o
magnésio, como vocês sabem, com a K2.
com Selena, com a Gotationa, é
impossível. Mas aí vem o sistema e fala:
"Ah, então não tem evidência científica
suficiente". Quantas vezes vocês não
viram isso no Instagram, né? Colega
ortodoxo puto com médico integrativo
falando assim: "Ah, isso aqui não tem
evidência, isso aqui não tem evidência,
né? Isso é uma baita de uma armadilha".
Olha a ironia,
esses mesmos RCTs que exigem imperfeição
para nutrientes, eles aprovam drogas com
efeitos colaterais às vezes brutais,
baseados em estudos patrocinados pela
BIC Farma, que vai lucrar muito com
esses estudos, né, com esses
medicamentos. Um cara lá da Polônia, é o
chamado Dr. Bill Grant, ele contou uma
história que vai te deixar de queixo
caído. Então em 2002, o INIA americano,
aquele órgão que é o órgão de defesa,
né, ou suposta defesa da saúde pública,
financiou um estudo de 3,6 milhões de
dólares, testando sabe o quê?
nitroglicerina para osteoporose.
Nitroglicerina é um remédio muito antigo
para doença coronariana, um vaso
dilatador. Então, os estudos anteriores
já tinham mostrado que a dose eficaz da
nitroglicerina era na faixa dos 40 mg
por dia. E adivinha o que que eles
fizeram? Os caras do NAID obrigaram o
pesquisador a reduzir a dose para 15 mg,
que é uma dose que sabidamente não
funciona. E qual foi o resultado óbvio?
O estudo provou, entre aspas, que não
funcionava. E por quê? Porque
nitroglicerina custa 5 por mês. Agora
deve tá custando até menos. E quant os
bis fosfonados em outras drogas aí da
linha do Prolia custam muito mais, né?
Mais de $ por meu. Mais de $ por mês.
Entenderam o jogo?
Vou dar um exemplo recente que aconteceu
na pandemia. Teve um estudo que
aconteceu lá no norte, se eu não me
engano, em Amazonas, que teve uma
cardiologista, inclusive é da minha
faculdade da UnB, e que ela virou uma
cardiologista famosa, porque ela passou
a ser parte do corpo clínico lá do
Hospital do Coração do HCOR. Ela fez um
estudo criminoso lá no norte com
hidroxicloroquina dando megados doses
pros pacientes. Para quê? Para provar
que não funciona. Olha só como é que é
canal do sistema.
Mas deixo te falar também algo mais
sério ainda. Recentemente sai uma
análise devastadora. Quase 400
medicamentos anticâncer, 400 pessoal
aprovados pela FDI nas últimas duas
décadas passaram pelos tais RCTs
maravilhosos, randomizados,
foram aprovados, viraram padrão de
tratamento. Sabe quanto de sobrevida
real esses remédios deram pros
pacientes? Semanas. ou poucos meses.
Isso mesmo que você ouviu, poucos meses.
E com que custo? Com toxicidade brutal,
qualidade de vida destruída, famílias
falidas, mas statisticamente foi um
sucesso porque foi significativo. Então
tá valendo, né? Isso que dá você dar um
valor excessivo à estatística, o tal do
P abaixo de 0,05.
Agora vamos falar da vitamina C na veia,
intravenosa eem alta dose, que é uma das
intervenções mais usadas pelos
moleculares, pelos integrativos. Os
mecanismos são cristalinos. Dependendo
da dose, a vitamina C em baixa dosagem
antioxidante, ela vai doar elétrons para
neutralizar radicais livres, vai
reciclar outros antioxidantes, vai
melhorar a síntese de colágeno e modular
a resposta imunológica. em altas doses
vai ser oxidativo, vai ter efeito
antimicrobiano e anticâncer. Então pode
ser usado para seps, para COVID, para
câncer. E médicos do mundo inteiro
observaram durante a pandemia melhorias
rápidas na oxigenação, redução de
vasopressores, recuperação de fadiga,
com uso de vitamina C em altas doses.
OK? Mas aí vem o sistema perguntando,
cadê o RCT fase 3 com milhares de
pacientes? O mesmo fase três que eles
não exigiram para a picadinha, né? Você
sabe o que eu tô falando. Então a
vitamina Ca
magnésio, com selênio, com vitaminas do
complexo B, com vitamina E.
E se o paciente estiver deficiente
nesses cofatores, o efeito é muito
menor. Mas o tal do RCT, né, com a
vitamina C não controla isso. Ele joga
todo mundo no mesmo bolo e tira uma
média.
Então é óbvio que pode dar resultado
inconclusivo.
E vamos ver o caso da vitamina D aqui, D
de dado. Isso aqui é um exemplo perfeito
da insanidade do sistema. Vitamina D não
é uma droga, é um hormônio que seu corpo
produz quando você toma sol. Então os
níveis variam com latitude, estação do
ano, cor da pele, idade, composição
corporal, dieta. São décadas de estudos
observacionais que mostram correlação
fortíssima entre níveis adequados de
vitamina D e redução de infecções de
câncer, de doenças autoimunes, redução
de mortalidade geral. Então, a cadeia
causal é bem estabelecida do ponto de
vista biológico. A vitamina D se liga ao
receptor VDR.
Vitamin D receptor regula mais de 1000
genes envolvidos em imunidade,
inflamação, diferenciação celular. E
tudo durante a pandemia de COVID,
metaanálises mostraram que níveis
adequados de vitamina D ou suplementação
estavam associados à redução
significativa de quê? Da mortalidade,
né? Então isso foi muito discutido na
pandemia, eu falei muito desse assunto e
tentaram tampar o sol com a peneira.
Então estamos falando aqui de redução de
58%
de mortalidade em alguns estudos com a
questão do nível adequado de vitamina D
durante a pandemia. Mas aí tem um cara
chamado Henry Lahor, né? Acho que é
assim que pronunciou o nome dele, ou
Laori, ou Lahori, que compilou 19 falhas
recorrentes nos estudos de vitamina D,
os estudos que você vê por aí que fala
que não funciona, que fazem eles darem
resultados negativos de proposta. Olha
só, canalice, deixa eu te dar alguns
exemplos. Eles usam doses ridículas,
tipo 200 ou 1000 unidades, quando você
precisa de muito mais.
fazem estudos curtos demais, proíbe o
uso de magnésio junto ou de vitamina K,
que são cofatores muito importantes. Não
fazem dose de ataque, usam vitamina D2
ao invés da D3, incluem pessoas que já
estão suplementando por conta própria,
definem insuficiência como se fosse 20
Nog por m quando o ideal é bem mais
alto. Eu trabalho um consultório entre
40 e 70.
E olha a cereja do bolo. Tem pesquisador
que ganhou o prêmio de 324.000
por concluir que 800 unidades não teve
efeito no osso. Claro que não teve, né,
o seu gênio. Essa dose é insuficiente,
né, mas missão cumprida ganhou o
dinheiro, embolsou e ludibriou a maioria
dos médicos para achar que vitamina D
não presta. E aí enterraram mais um
nutriente barato e eficaz. Agora segura
essa neacina, a vitamina B de bola 3,
ela existe desde antes das estatinas,
muito antes como tratamento para as
deslipidemias, colesterol alto, é o mais
potente agente para aumentar HDL. Eu
passo bastante o o na forma de exa
nicotinato, porque infelizmente a
neacina de liberação rápida dá o flush
que é bem desconfortável, né? aquele
vermelhão no rosto. Enfim, é muito bom
para aumentar o HD colesterol e para
reduzir também trigliceridos. Além
disso, o nada de mais, além disso, a
vitamina B3 aumenta, o nada de mais, né,
que é a nicotinamida adenosina de
fosfato, que a coenzima é essencial
paraa energia mitocondrial e pro reparo
de DNA. Então, por décadas, resultados
favoráveis. Aí vem a indústria
farmacêutica, patrocina dois estudos,
tá? Esses dois estudos é o M high High e
o HPS2 Five, que usou versões sintéticas
de liberação prolongada da vitamina B3
associado a estatinas e criou efeitos
colaterais e fatores de confusão. Então,
qual foi a conclusão dos estudos? Nem a
cina não tem benefício. Pronto, aí já
enterraram mais um nutriente maravilhoso
e barato para tratar da saúde.
Mas na vida real, usando ncina pura.
Seja liberação lenta ou imediata, eu
gosto, eu gosto mais da liberação lenta
porque como eu falei, dá o flush.
Médicos continuam vendo melhoras
consistentes na gordura do sangue, nos
lipídios, na função hidotelial, na
inflamação por um custo muito menor.
Então, de novo, não foi a neacina que
falhou, foi o desenho do estudo que foi
manipulado. E tem uma coisa que pouca
gente sabe, a neacina foi o nutriente
que fundou a medicina ortomolecular. né?
Eu li um livro alguns meses atrás do Abn
Hofer, que conta essa história. Então,
lá nos anos 1950, o Dr. Abn Hofer, um
psiquiatra canadense, começou a usar
neacina em alta dose para tratar
esquizofrenia.
Os resultados foram impressionantes,
teve menos recaídas, normalização do
metabolismo das catecolaminas. E isso
inspirou o Dr. Linus Paulin, que em 1968
publicou o artigo Psiquiatria
ortomolecular na revista Science.
cunhando o termo que deu origem a todo
esse movimento, restaurar a saúde mental
e física, otimizando as concentrações de
moléculas naturalmente presentes no
corpo. Então, o Hoffer foi um dos
fundadores da medicina ortomolecular.
Então o R Hofer viu a neacina não como
uma vitamina qualquer, mas como um
regulador metabólico que repõe o NAD+ e
o NAD P+ restaurando o balanço redox, ou
seja, melhorando toda sistema de
antioxidação da célula. Então, também
aumentando a produção de energia
mitocondrial
e estabilidade dos neurotransmissores.
Então, décadas de trabalho clínico e
bioquímico do Dr. Abon Hofer formaram a
base da psiquiatriacular
e da medicina metabólica integrativa
moderna. Então hoje a neacina continua
sendo a pedra angular simbólica e mec
mecanística, né, da medicina molecular,
mostrando como intervenções baseadas em
nutrientes, quando fundamentadas em
lógica bioquímica e aplicação
individualizada, consegue o que o manejo
farmacológico de sintomas muitas vezes
não consegue. E sabe o que que é mais
revoltante? Em 73, 2 anos antes do
nascer, né? A Associação Americana de
Psiquiatria criou uma força tarefa sobre
megaavitaminas e terapia autobolecular
lá atrás, hein, gente, foi a primeira
grande arma institucional usando
ortodoxia, usando essa metodologia que
eu já falei que é furada dos RCTS
contra o sucesso clínico real. Então, a
terapia de neacina, Dr. Abram Hoffer
tinha décadas já de sucesso nesse
momento, um cerca de 20 anos aí.
e fundamento bioquímico sólido. Mas aí a
APA descartou tudo por falta de
evidência controlada, sendo que os
próprios contraestudos deles eram
metodologicamente mais fracos e muito
mais curtos. Então esse episódio criou o
precedente que ainda governa a política
médica. Se uma intervenção não se
encaixa no modelo de RCT, ela é rotulada
como inválida. Não importa quantos
pacientes melhorem.
Então vamos falar da dieta low carb.
cetogênica, né? Diabetes tipo 2, por
exemplo, obesidade, síndometabólica,
Alzheimer, tudo isso é reversível, ah,
no caso do Alzheimer, no começo,
obviamente, né? Através da restrição de
carboidratos e cetose nutricional.
Então, nós temos aí milhares de
pacientes, múltiplos estudos
longitudinais demonstrando isso, gente
também que melhorou até da depressão com
a dieta acetogênica bem feita, tá,
pessoal? né? Aquela cetogênica que o
pessoal confunde com a dieta deátic
hiperproteica,
mas a medicina mainstream
durante anos citando ausência de RCTs de
longo prazo. Então você não consegue
capturar facilmente aderência dietética,
adaptação metabólica, balanço
nutricional individualizado, fazendo o
RCT. Como é que você vai avalier isso se
não tem como isolar tudo? Então, mesmo
assim, dados do mundo real, da Virta
Heal e de outros mostraram redução
sustentada de hemoglobina glicada, perda
de peso, descontinuação de medicamentos
ao longo de 2 a 5 anos, que é uma
magnitude que raramente se vê em estudos
com drogas. E nós sabemos que o
mecanismo é direto, é redução dos
carboidratos da dieta, que vai diminuir
a glicose pósprandial, a glicose pós
alimentação, vai reduzir insulina e
reduzindo a insulina vai reduzir também
inflamação, estresse oxidativo e vai
restaurar flexibilidade mitocondrial.
Então, essas vias causais são
mensuráveis, são previsíveis, são
reproduzíveis e atendem a todo critério
de validade científica, exceto o
problema da randomização que tem nos
RCTs. Randomização seria aquela
aleatorização, né?
E os protocolos de detox também são
impossíveis de randomizar eticamente.
Você não pode expor voluntários
deliberadamente a agentes agressivos,
né, a venenos como mercúrio, chumbo,
glifosato, só para poder criar um grupo
placebo. Isso seria totalmente
antiético. Mais biomarcadores como
glutationa, gama GT, painéis de toxinas
urinares mostram melhora repetidas após
desintoxicação nutricional com vitamina
C, com ácidofalipôico, comcisteína,
antioxidantes de forma direcionada.
Então, da perspectiva de uma abordagem
funcional,
isso é interferência, aliás, isso é
inferência causal em ação. Você pode
remover toxinas que vai melhorar a
função mitocondrial, vai se recuperar e
vai levar à melhora dos sintomas. Então,
ficar esperando um estudo randomizado de
exposição à toxina não faz sentido, nem
é ciência, é uma paralisia metodológica.
Então, o que que a gente faz? Nós
precisamos de um novo modelo. Esse
modelo cartesiano atual, ele tá muito
limitado. Então, a modelagem causal faz
uma pergunta diferente. Quais mecanismos
ligam intervenção à bioquímica e ao
resultado clínico? Ao invés de apagar as
diferenças, tirando a média, ela abraça
a individualidade usando biomarcadores,
raciocínio mecanístico, probabilidade
baesiana para inferir causa e efeito a
partir de múltiplos fluxos de evidência,
tá? Eu falei difícil agora, né? Falei,
parece até que eu tô inteligente agora.
Isso espelha como os clínicos realmente
pensam.
Então, quando a deficiência vitamina D
se correlaciona com disfunção imune ou
estresse oxidativo e desfechos ruins e a
suplementação restaura a função, isso é
inferência causal, não é coincidência.
Então, quando o jejum melhora a
sensibilidade insulina através de
culturas,
não precisamos de um RCT
de 10 anos para poder acreditar no que
nós estamos vendo, né?
Então, a medicina automolecular, ela
pratica a modelagem causal já tem
décadas, então muito antes do termo
virar moda. Então, dentro da medicina
molecular é observado a individualidade
bioquímica, a correção de deficiências
mensuráveis, o rastreio de desfechos.
Então, a lógica ela é bem transparente,
é bem reproduzível, é ou reprodutível, é
biologicamente sólida. a vitamina C em
alta dose, a otimização de vitamina D, a
terapia comacina, a nutrição cetogênica
e lowcarb. Tudo isso segue vias
mecanicísticas que podem ser medidas e
previstas. Então isso é vidência do
mundo real, é baseado em causa raiz, que
é eticamente sólido,
centrado no paciente. Então nós
valorizamos fisiologia acima de
estatísticas, cura acima de teste de
hipóteses, porém ironicamente é mais
científico que o ritual de randomização
divorciado da biologia. Então temos que
considerar que é hora de recuperar a
ciência das garras das estatísticas.
Ciência deveria ser um método de
descoberta, não sacerdócio de valores P.
Então, os RCTs têm sim o seu lugar, tem
o seu papel para aprovação de drogas,
para eficácia de curto prazo, para
triagem, toxicidade, mas não como
árbitro supremo da verdade. Quando a
metodologia vira ideologia, a medicina
perde humildade e também humanidade.
Então, a hora de reclamar,
evidência como um contínuo. é a
plausibilidade mecanística
relacionado à bioquímica, fisiologia,
observação clínica em casos de pacientes
reais, com resultados reais e com
validação estatística quando é
apropriado e quando for ético, né? Vocês
lembram aquela história do para-quedas,
né? Então, todos nós sabemos que
paraquedas ele funciona. Então, ninguém
faria um estudo e duplo cego
randomizado. Um cara pula do avião com
paraquedas e o outro pula sem
para-quedas para ver, para provar que o
cara que pulou sem para-queda vai morrer
e o outro vai sobreviver. Então isso aí
é um problema que nós temos RCTs. Muitas
vezes você tem uma evidência muito clara
eh de empirismo de centenas de anos e
que você não tem prova pro RCT porque
seria antiético você subeter uma pessoa
a um risco desnecessário, porque você
sabe muito bem que aquilo funciona, né?
Então a medicina integrativa e a
medicina eles incorporam essa
hierarquia, OK?
Nós começamos pelo mecanismo,
confirmamos através da experiência e nós
refinamos com dados e não o contrário.
Então a falha não tá no processo
matemático de randomização, mas no
monopólio dela sobre a verdade. Então ao
intronizar RCTS com uma única evidência
válida cartesiana, a medicina moderna se
cegou paraa biologia, paraa nutrição,
para sistemas complexos e pelo bom
senso. Então é hora de evoluir da
randomização para razão, controle por
entendimento, das estatísticas para
causalidade, porque a saúde não é
aleatória, a nossa evidência também não
deveria ser.
E essa obsessão por um modelo
estatístico divorciado da biologia não
só enterra soluções boas como a neacina
e vitamina D, ela também abre a porta
para aprovar intervenções novas sem
entender de verdade o que que elas estão
fazendo no nosso corpo. É o caso que
estamos vendo agora com as novas
tecnologias das picadinhas RNA
mensageiro. Bem, antes de eu continuar,
eu gostaria de saber se vocês estão
acompanhando o que eu tô dizendo. Hélio,
por favor, se manifeste. Cristina
também. Dra. Ana Paula tem alguns
comentários aqui, ó.
Eh, boa noite a todos da comunidade
avançada. Creio que teremos ótimos
momentos. Sim, com certeza. Liberação
lenta, evita o flush ou vermelhidão do
rosto. Tá falando aqui da B3.
História da medicina é algo fascinante.
Gratidão por trazer a luz. Obrigado
pelos comentários, doutora.
Bem, Cristina e Hélio, parece que são
vocês que estão acompanhando.
Por gentileza, me digam se vocês
entenderam, se tem algum aspecto dessa
primeira parte da live que vocês querem
discutir antes da gente prosseguir. Eu
vou esperar aí uns 2 minutos. Enquanto
isso eu vou pegar um pouquinho de água
para mim, tá? Vamos, gente, só.
Ah.
[Música]
Comentário da Cristina. A explicação foi
excelente. Muito obrigado. Ficou alguma
dúvida, Cristina, sobre a explicação?
Ah, falei difícil demais. Alguns trechos
ficaram realmente um pouquinho mais
difíceis, né? Mas me digam se vocês
entenderam, tem alguma dúvida antes da
gente prosseguir. Dúvida sobre esse
tema, tá, pessoal? A live de perguntas
não é hoje, né? É na terça-feira, vocês
sabem disso. Só pra gente não ficar
perdendo tempo com muita pergunta, né?
Mas é só pra gente ver se o assunto que
eu falei agora eh vocês
metabolizaram, entenderam? Tem alguma
dúvida?
Beleza, vou continuar aqui, tá? Hã,
lembrando que fica gravado os vídeos
para quem tem acesso ao nível dois.
Bem, vamos falar aqui então das
tecnologias de mRNA, mensageiro das
picadinhas, né? Olha só, você vai numa
situação hipotética, tomar a terceira
dose do reforço. Em 48 horas o seu corpo
está completamente diferente. Eu não tô
falando de dor no braço ou cansaço, não.
Eu tô falando de marcadores
inflamatórios duplicando, células de
defesa despencando e seu sangue ficando
mais propenso a formar coágulos.
E sabe o que que é mais intrigante? A
pessoa continua se sentindo bem, achando
que tá tudo normal. é a tal da bomba
relógio silenciosa que ninguém te conta.
Então, acabou de sair um estudo
longitudinal de 6 meses, foi publicado
em julho de 2025,
avaliou 68 jovens adultos saudáveis
depois da terceira dose da Pfizer.
Os pesquisadores lá da King Abdulazis
University na Arábia Saudita, que foram
liderados pelo Dr. Walid Bauazir,
fizeram algo que raramente se vê.
acompanharam esses jovens de perto,
mediram marcadores específicos antes e
depois da vacinação. E o que que eles
descobriram? Eu vou ser bem direto com
você, alterações preocupantes. Então
vamos começar pela inflamação, que é o
coração do problema. A proteína
serreativa, aquele marcador de
inflamação que todo mundo pede, pelo
menos todo mundo que eu conheço da
medicina integrativa pede em checkup.
saltou de 6,12 para 14,8 mg por LRO em
apenas 2 dias. Então isso é praticamente
o dobro. A PCR de alta sensibilidade
também dobrou indo de 1,4 para 3,5.
Agora deixa eu traduzir isso para você
em termos práticos. Quando a gente vê
esses valores subindo desse jeito, nós
estamos vendo o corpo entrando no estado
inflamatório sistêmico agudo. E
inflamação crônica é aquela porta de
entrada pro monte de encrenca
cardiovascular e metabólica que aparece
lá na frente.
Mas espera que tem mais. Os dedímeros,
né, que são aqueles marcadores que a
gente usa para avaliar trombose, tromb,
principalmente trombose pulmonar, né,
subiram de 0,2 para 0,4 mg por L.
Ou seja, o sangue ficou com tendência
protrombótica,
mais propenso a formar coágulos. E não
precisa ser gênio para saber que
coágulos no lugar errado causar trombose
pulmonar, como eu falei que é o TEP,
tromboembolia pulmonar, AVC isquêmico,
tá? E trombose e outros territórios.
Agora vem a parte que deixa eu bastante
preocupado. Os linfócitos, que são as
células de defesa fundamentais no
sistema imune, caíram de maneira
significativa. Foram de 2,3 para 1,9
bilhões de unidades por litro. E tem
mais o interferon gama, que é uma
proteína muito importante, essencial
para defesa antiviral, caiu de 54 para
46 ng por mil. E o que quer dizer isso
na prática? Que o sistema imunológico
for mais fraco, mais vulnerável. E isso
é bem paradoxal, porque isso deveria est
protegendo as pessoas. Você toma algo
que teoricamente deveria tá te ajudando,
mas temporariamente você fica com as
defesas comprometidas. Isso estudo,
gente, não é teoria da conspiração. Eu
sei que tem muita gente fica bravo
comigo quando eu falo desse assunto. Eu
não sei se os membros novos do canal, o
que que eles pensam sobre isso, tá? Mas
vamos lá.
Olha só a sutileza desse problema. O
tempo de protrombina e o tempo de
tromboplastina passe ativada ficaram
prolongados. Então são aqueles exames de
coagulação que a gente pede antes da
cirurgia. Então, esses padrões são
exatamente os mesmos que aparecem em
caso de miocardite, pericardite e outras
síndromes trombóticas que são induzidas
por picadinha. E veja bem, essas pessoas
não tinham sintoma nenhum. Parecia tudo
bem por fora, mas por dentro tava
rolando essa bagunça.
Recentemente sai um estudo publicado
também na revista Vaccines de agosto
desse ano, 25 sobre a inflamação
endotelial sistêmica. Então, os
pesquisadores mostraram que as vacinas
de RNA mensageiro podem causar um
espectro amplo de inflamação no
revestimento dos vasos sanguíneos. E
isso explicaria muita coisa que a gente
tá vendo na prática clínica. D Ana Paula
que tá aqui vascular, ela sabe, eu
também tenho visto, as complicações
cardiovasculares e problemas
neurológicos que algumas pessoas
relatam. Tem uma coisa que a literatura
científica vem mostrando que é polêmica
também, mas que eu preciso dizer,
alguns estudos sugere que tem uma
supressão de resposta do interferon tipo
um. Então, o interferon ele é
fundamental para controlar infecções
virais, vigilância também contra o
câncer. Teve uma pesquisa publicada em
2022 no Food and Chemical Toxicology que
gerou bastante controvérsia, que
levantou essa questão. Claro que teve
crítica, claro que teve eh debate
científico acalorado,
mas os dados estão aí. Outros estudos
japoneses, eu gosto muito de japoneses,
que eles têm coragem de publicar estudo
que não é politicamente correto. Então,
esse estudo do Fukushima Vaccination
Community Survey mostrou que depois da
quinta dose tinha uma proporção maior de
pessoas que não conseguiram desenvolver
imunidade celular adequada.
Bem, o ponto aqui, pessoal, não é dizer
que a picadinha de RNA mensageiro é o
capeta, né? Então, durante a pandemia,
né, elas podem ter tido algum papel,
mas, eh, como vocês sabem, elas foram
liberadas com muita rapidez e sem os
estudos devidos, né? Agora, elas foram
dados indiscriadamente para muita gente
e nós estamos vendo a consequência
agora, né?
Bem, aí tem o estudo que diz que a
efetividade da picadinha de RNA
mensageiro contra hospitalização foi de
reduzir supostamente 46 a 56%
a hospitalização, né? Isso aí a gente
não sabe se isso foi manipulado ou não,
tá? Eh, mas temos que entender que
qualquer tipo de intervenção aí ideia na
população geral que vacina fosse algo
totalmente inóco, né? Eles fazem aquela
história do Zé Gotinha como se fosse uma
vitamina, fosse uma coisa muito
inocente. Não é assim, gente. É um
fármaco e todo fármaco tem efeitos
colaterais.
Então, o grande problema é que muita
gente acha que reação diversa é só
sentir alguma coisa, é dor no braço ou
febre, mas esses estudos mostram que
está rolando uma cascata de eventos
biológicos bem mais complexos e
potencialmente perigosos a nível
celular. E o mais preocupante é que isso
acontece em jovens saudáveis, sem
comorbidade, o pessoal que tinha risco
baixíssimo de complicação grave pela
doença original. OK? Então esse é o
grande problema, que a complicação tá
pior do que a doença.
Tô falando para adultos jovens, tá? que
tinha um baixo risco.
Tem alto precisa ficar claro aqui. Esses
efeitos aparecem rápido em 48 horas, mas
a gente não sabe ainda qual que é o
impacto a longo prazo. Então, será que
essa inflamação endotelial, né, da
parente interna nas artérias, de maneira
repetida pela protein spike, essas
alterações de coagulação, essa supressão
imunológica transitória vão deixar
alguma sequela? Fica esse ponto de
interrogação? Eu acho que sim, né? Todo
mundo que tá observando tá chegando à
mesma conclusão, porém é uma pergunta
que ainda não tem resposta definitiva.
Ah, agora eu vi aqui uma mensagem, não
estou conseguindo acessar o link,
informa que é somente para membros.
Deixa eu responder Ana Lúcia aqui no
grupo.
Precisa
assinar o nível dois.
Eu
publiquei um vídeo sobre isso
recentemente.
Pronto, só para avisar ela aqui. Vamos
continuar.
Então, na abordagem integrativa, como
vocês sabem, a gente sempre fala de
olhar o indivíduo como um todo, de
avaliar o custo benefício de forma
personalizada. Então, um jovem de 20
anos saudável tem um perfil de risco
completamente diferente de um idoso 75
anos com diabetes e doença
cardiovascular, mas as recomendações
geralmente são iguais para todo mundo em
relação às picadinhas. Será que isso faz
sentido, pessoal? Eu acho que não, né?
Paula tem um comentário para fazer aqui.
Isso seria algo responsável pela
ativação de vários vírus que verificamos
nesse póspand, principalmente seomal
vírus, herps, vírus e epistem bar, né,
pessoal? Também tem outra coisa, a
transparência nos dados é fundamental.
Quando aparecem estudos mostrando essas
alterações, a reação não pode ser de
negação censura. Tem que ser de
investigação, tem que ser de querer
entender o que tá acontecendo, que a
ciência avança quando a gente questiona,
quando a gente olha pros dados
inconvenientes e tenta explicá-los.
Olha, eu sei que esse assunto é
polêmico. Muita gente aqui vai ficar
incomodado com o que eu estou falando
aqui, né? Eh, mas eu tenho um papel
social como médico e se você não
concorda, simplesmente descarte essas
informações. A minha obrigação é trazer
informação baseada em evidência, mesmo
quando ela não é uma informação popular
ou qual é o caso aqui de uma coisa que
muita gente não quer, não quer escutar.
Então, os estudos estão publicados em
várias revistas científicas séries, no
Frontiers, em Cellular and Infection
Microbiology, no vacines, no Nature
Communications, no Canadian Journal of
Cardiology. Então, não é maluquice, não
é teoria da conspiração, é a literatura
científica que está surgindo aos poucos.
Então, se você está considerando tomar
dose de reforço, converse com o seu
médico, pergunte sobre os marcadores
inflamatórios. sobre o perfil de risco
individual. Será que no seu caso
específico o benefício supera o risco?
Eu entendo que não, tá? É minha opinião
pessoal, mas eu acho que as pessoas têm
o direito de conversar com seus médicos
e tomar sua decisão. Então, a decisão
que precisa ser individualizada e não
generalizada.
E e para quem já tomou então várias
picadinhos, o que fazer? Bom, ficar
ligado nos sinais. Se tiver cansaço
excessivo, falta de ar, palpitação, dor
no peito, tem que fazer investigação,
né? Pode não ser nada, pode ser uma
crise de ansiedade, né, como é muito
comum, mas pode ser aquele sinalzinho de
que algo não está certo. E se você é
daqueles que pega infecção atrás de
infecção, que tem a imunidade aí
comprometida, vale a pena investigar se
o seu sistema imune tá funcionando e se
pode ser algum tipo de efeito colateral,
né, dessas soluções aí, né, injetáveis.
Então, nós sabemos que a medicina está
mudando. A gente tá entrando numa era
onde a tecnologia avança muito rápido e
às vezes mais rápido do que a nossa
capacidade de absorver ou entender as
consequências. Então, as soluções aí de
RNA mensageiro, as picadinhas são
consideradas revolucionárias. A
tecnologia é revolucionada, mas lembre
que o Robert Maloni, que fez parte lá da
equipe que desenvolveu essa tecnologia,
ele fala muito mal delas, né?
Toda a revolução pode trazer desafios e
o desafio agora é entender o que
aconteceu, né, com essas soluções
injetáveis e equilibrar os supostos
benefícios comparando com os riscos,
especialmente utilizando essa literatura
mais recente. Então fica a reflexão,
será que a gente está fazendo as
perguntas corretas? Será que estamos
acompanhando adequadamente quem tomou a
picadinha? Será que o modelo de
recomendação única para todos faz
sentido numa medicina que cada vez mais
entende a importância da
individualização?
São perguntas que precisam ser feitas,
discutidas e pesquisadas, porque no
final das contas estamos falando de
saúde pública, estamos falando de
bilhões de idosos administradas,
se não for, se não foram trilhões, né?
Estamos falando de você, da sua família,
da saúde, de uma geração inteira, que
vai ser o pessoal que vai assumir aí eh
o mercado de trabalho daqui alguns anos,
né? Esse padrão de inflamação
e de ignorar o dano sistêmico, essa
cegueira, né, pro terreno biológico.
Isso nós vemos na pesquisa, né, das
vacinas e vemos talvez de forma ainda
mais trágica na maneira como tratamos o
câncer. Então, olha só, eu vou ser
direto. Se eu te perguntar agora qual é
o maior erro da oncologia moderna, apó
que você vai me dizer não descobrir a
cura ou focar demais em químio né? Mas a
verdade é muito mais profunda e
assustadora. O grande erro é simples
assim. A medicina convencional está
tentando matar o câncer, matando você
junto muitas vezes e nem as pessoas
estão percebendo sobre isso. Então vou
contar uma história aqui que acabou de
acontecer num congresso de medicina
oncológica, novembro agora desse ano,
esse mês já lá nos Estados Unidos, um
dos maiores nomes da medicinacular
mundial levantou uma questão que fez a
plateia inteira ficar em silêncio. A
pergunta era sobre glutaminólise,
tá? Já vou explicar o que que é isso. E
a resposta dele virou um artigo
científico que estourou agora em
novembro. E olha, esse artigo derruba
décadas de pesquisa em câncer, tá? E
bilhões de dólares jogados fora, porque
a lógica estava errada desde o começo.
Então você já parou para pensar por com
tanto avanço tecnológico a gente
continua perdendo a guerra contra o
câncer? Pois é, e tem um motivo para
isso. E hoje eu vou te mostrar
exatamente onde está o erro.
E mais importante ainda, o que que essa
abordagem integrativa faz diferente?
Porque enquanto a medicina tradicional
tenta cortar o combustível do tumor, ela
esquece um detalhe crucial, que esse
mesmo combustível mantém você vivo.
Então vamos lá, sem rodeios. Glutamina é
um aminoácido muito importante. Pensa
nele como uma espécie de supercbustível
do seu corpo. Ela alimenta as células
intestinais, turbina o sistema imune,
protege células contra radicais livres e
mantém os músculos funcionando
direitinho. É basicamente essencial pra
vida, mas aí vem o câncer que é esperto
para caramba, e começa a usar essa mesma
glutamina como combustível. Então,
câncer usa principalmente glicose, mas
também usa glutamina para crescer, para
se multiplicar e para se espalhar.
Então, o que que a indústria
farmacêutica fez? Vamos pensar então se
o tumor usa a grutamina, vamos bloquear
a glutamina, né? E faria bastante
sentido, né? Só que não, porque é tipo
você descobrir que o ladrão tá usando a
mesma estrada que você usa para ir
trabalhar todo dia e aí você resolve
explodir a estrada, né? Problema é
resolvido, sim. O ladrão não passa mais,
mas você também não passa mais. E olha
que interessante, desde 2010, mais ou
menos, a ciência vem martelando nisso,
artigos e mais artigos, mostrando como
as células do câncer dependem dessa tal
de glutaminólise, que é a quebra da
glutamina para gerar energia. Então eles
criaram remédios caríssimos para
bloquear a formação e a quebra de
glutamina. fizeram estudos em ratos, em
células, em laboratórios de última
geração, todo mundo achando que era o
caminho da salvação.
Só que aí vem a parte que ninguém te
conta. Sabe o que aconteceu quando
testaram humano de verdade? Foi um
fracasso total. Os estudos clínicos que
deveriam revolucionar o tratamento do
câncer simplesmente não funcionaram. um
remédio chamado telaglenast,
não sei porque que eles dão dão esses
nomes tão esquisito, que era a grande
esperança da indústria, que era esse
bloqueador de glutamina, foi testado em
câncer de rim e câncer de mama triplo
negativo, que é o mais agressivo. O
resultado nada, zero benefício.
O estudo Cantata que foi publicado em
2022 que testou esse tal de telaglenast
combinado com carbosantinibe
em 444 pacientes com câncer renal
avançado. Sabe o que aconteceu? Qual foi
a diferença da sobrevida livre de
progressão? Nenhuma, né? Foi 9,2 meses
com remédio caro vezes 9,3 meses com
placebo. Então você leu certo o grupo
que recebeu essa droga caríssima.
eh, viveu menos do que o grupo placebo.
E olha que bacana, 62% desses pacientes
já tinham sido tratados com imunoterapia
antes, ou seja, eram pacientes que
precisavam desesperadamente de algo que
funcionasse porque já estavam fazendo
uso da última cartada, digamos assim, e
mesmo assim não funcionou.
E tem mais, em 2025 saiu outro estudo
combinando telaglenast
com o nivulum,
que é uma imunoterapia super cara em
pacientes com melanoma, câncer de rim e
câncer de pulmão. E qual foi o
resultado? Uma taxa de resposta global
de 8%, só 8,4%.
E olha que interessante, os efeitos
colaterais foram significativos. teve
fadiga em 42% dos pacientes, náusea em
40%, fotofobia em 32%, ou seja, o
pessoal sofreu
os efeitos adversos, mas não teve
benefício algum.
E por que será? Deixa eu te explicar de
um jeito que você nunca vai esquecer. O
corpo humano não é burro. Ele tem
milhões de anos de evolução, lógico,
considerando todas as espécies que
vieram antes. Quando você tenta bloquear
uma via metabólica essencial, o
organismo dá um jeito. Então, as células
do câncer simplesmente mudam de
combustível. Então, isso é uma grande
crítica que eu tenho, aquela visão lá do
modelo do Arberg, né, que o pessoal
fala: "Ah, não, é só cortar a glicose do
câncer, tá resolvido". Não é assim,
gente. O câncer se adapta, tá? Então
existe vários cânceres aí que queimam
gordura como combustível, ácidos
grassos. Então, voltando essa esse
ponto, as células do câncer mudam de
combustível, começam a usar mais
glicose, pegam outros aminoácidos e se
adaptam. Mas sabe quem não consegue se
adaptar tão fácil assim? As células
normais. Então, as células do intestino
que precisam de glutamina para manter a
barreira intestinal funcionando são
ferradas, né? A gente sabe que essas
células se renovam a cada três dias. Os
linfócitos, soldados de defesa, do
sistema imune que deveriam estar lutando
contra o câncer, ficam enfraquecidos. E
a capacidade de produzir glutationa, que
é o antioxidante mestre mais poderoso do
corpo, também fica comprometida. Os
músculos que usam glutamina para regular
o equilíbrio ácido básico durante o
estresse de exercício ou de doença
também são prejudicados.
Mas pera aí, deixa eu ver se eu entendi.
A gente bloqueia uma substância
essencial para tentar matar o tumor.
Tumor dá um jeito, continua crescendo,
mas o paciente fica cada vez mais fraco,
com intestino ferrado, imunidade baixa e
músculos derretendo. Então isso não é
tratamento, isso é quase uma sabotagem.
E tem mais uma coisa que a medicina
convencional insiste em ignorar. Nem
todo mundo é viciado em glutamina.
Desculpa, nem todo mundo não. Nem todo
tumor é viciado e glutamina da mesma
forma. Tem tumor que usa, tem tumor que
nem liga tanto assim, mas os remédios
que bloqueiam glutamina não fazem
extinção, eles bloqueiam para todo mundo
de forma indiscriminada. Então é como
usar bomba atômica para matar mosquito.
Funciona talvez.
Mas será que vale a pena? Até o momento
não parece valer a pena.
E olha só que revelador, nos anos 70 e
80 já tinham testado análogos de
glutamina, substâncias como o don, a
acvicina e a asacerina. E sabe o que
aconteceu? Toxicidade limitante de dose,
neurotoxicidade, toxicidade
gastrointestinal grave, supressão da
medula óssea, tiveram que abandonar tudo
porque os pacientes morriam dos efeitos
colaterais antes de qualquer benefício
aparecer. E aí, décadas depois eles
voltam com a mesma ideia, só que com
drogas mais seletivas. E deu no quê? no
mesmo fracasso, só que com marketing
melhor. Tem um detalhe técnico
importante aqui que você precisa
entender. Esses inibidores de
glutaminase, é o caso das drogas BPTES
e o CB839,
eles bloqueiam especificamente a enzima
que converte glutamina em glutamato.
Então parece muito específico, até
cirúrgico, mas o problema é que essa
enzima não trabalha só pro tumor, ela
trabalha também para suas células que
precisam de glutamina. E quando você
bloqueia ela, você não tá sendo seletivo
coisíssima nenhuma. Até tentaram
melhorar a biodisponibilidade dessas
drogas, fazendo o quê? encapsulando em
nanopartículas,
modificaram a estrutura química, criaram
prodrogas que teoricamente deveriam ser
ativadas só no tumor, mas na prática
quando chegou na clínica, nos pacientes
reais foi fracasso atrás de fracasso e
um troço super caro com tecnologia de
ponta. E a literatura científica de 24 e
25 tá cheia desses fracassos, só que
eles não aparecem na manchete dos
jornais porque não dá uma boa mídia, né?
não dá uma boa propaganda, não dá ibope
falar de remédio que não funcionou e
custou caríssimo para desenvolver.
Agora vamos falar na parte boa, a parte
que muda tudo, a parte que a abordagem
integrativa olha para isso de um jeito
completamente diferente. Em vez de
perguntar como é que eu mato o câncer, a
gente pergunta por esse corpo criou um
ambiente onde o câncer consegue
prosperar. Então, deu para entender a
diferença? É uma mudança de paradigma
completo, porque olha só, câncer não é
uma doença que cai do céu. Câncer é uma
resposta adaptativa a um terreno
biológico que está ruim. Toxinas
ambientais, deficiências nutricionais,
inflamação crônica descontrolada,
sistema imune desregulado, desequilíbrio
hormonal, estresse psicológico intenso,
disfunção mitocondrial. Tudo isso cria
um ambiente ruim e perfeito pro câncer
se desenvolver. E o terreno é muito
importante, sempre foi o terreno. Aí
você chega com medicina convencional,
querendo bloquear a glutamina, achando
que vai resolver, mas não conserta nada
do que causou problema. É como tentar
apagar um incêndio sem desligar o que tá
causando fogo. Você pode até controlar
as chamas por um tempo, mas enquanto a
faísca continua acesa, vai ter mais
fogo. Então a visão integrativa, por
outro lado, trabalha na raiz. A gente
não quer privar o corpo de nada
essencial. A gente quer restaurar,
otimizar, reconstruir o terreno para que
ele volte a ser hostil ao câncer e mais
favorável à vida normal. E como nós
fazemos isso? Primeiro, suficiência de
micronutrientes. Aqui tem um ponto
crucial que a literatura científica
recente agora de 25 reforça. Vitamina C
em doses terapêuticas intravenosas não é
vitamina C de farmácia, não é suco de
laranja, é vitamina C em altas doses
endovenoso, doses farmacológicas de 1 a
1,5 g por kg de peso corporal. A gente
começa com 10 g, vai para 20, 30, 40,
50,
né? vai aumentando progressivamente a
dose. Essa é a dose proxidativa, né?
Porque a vitamina C nessa dose alta, ela
vai entrar na célula, vai gerar o
peróxido de hidrogênio no ambiente
extracelular. Isso mata células
cancerígenas e poupa células normais que
têm mecanismos antioxidantes funcionando
ainda. E olha que interessante, um
artigo agora desse ano também publicado
na Frontiers em mostrou que a vitamina C
endovenosa em altas doses tem atividade
citotóxica seletiva contra tumores
através de dano ao DNA mediado por
espécies reativas de oxigênio, depressão
de ATP, regulação negativa do
metabolismo do citrato, ou seja, ela
ataca o tumor por várias vias
simultâneas. Não é um mecanismo único
que o tumor pode contornar. São vários
de uma vez. Mas aí você pode me
perguntar, Dr. Alan, se funciona tão
bem, porque que ninguém usa, ou seja, ou
porque a maioria não usa simples, não dá
para patentear a vitamina C, né? Então é
uma coisa de ortomolecular que eles
torcem o nariz, é uma substância
natural, não pode ser patenteada e sem
patente não tem esse lucro bilionário
que essas drogas caríssimas
proporcionam. Então, a indústria
farmacêutica não investe em estudos
grandes, randomizados, que poderiam
provar definitivamente e cimentar logo
essa história da eficácia da vitamina C.
Então, eles preferem investir bilhões em
drogas como o T lá grlenastátic e foi um
fiasco, né? Mas porque elas podem ser
patenteadas e podem ser vendidas a peso
de ouro, né? E obrigar os governos a a
pagar essa conta aí que sai sai dos
impostos, né, pessoal?
Então, o estudo de 2024 do National
Cancer Institute testou vitamina C
endovenosa
combinada com quimioterapia em câncer de
próstata e câncer de e pâncreas, né? E
sabe o que que eles encontraram nos
pacientes com câncer de próstata que
receberam a vitamina C junto com doce
taxel?
Não houve melhora, mas espera aí, tem um
porém importante. Eles usaram dose única
de 1 g por kg quando o protocolo
riordan, que é um dos mais conhecidos
molecular e é considerado padrão ouro na
abordagem integrativa, recomenda doses
repetidas três vezes por semana até
atingir níveis plasmáticos específicos,
ou seja, testaram errado e concluíram
que não funciona. Então é sempre assim,
testam de forma subótima com doses
inadequadas. frequência errada e aí
falam: "Olha, não funciona, né?" Como eu
falei, igual o estudo lá que teve da
hidroxicloroquina lá no norte, igual o
estudo que eu comentei da vitamina B3 ou
da vitamina D. Mas quando você pega os
protocolos bem feitos, com doses
adequadas de vitamina C, com a
frequência adequada, né? Aí você vai
subindo até chegar a 50 ou 100 g por
sessão, se for uma pessoa mais pesada e
tem que ser feito três vezes por semana.
Os resultados são completamente
diferentes. Os pacientes toleram melhor
a químia, tem menos fadiga, melhor
qualidade de vida. Em muitos casos
resposta tumoral melhorada. E tem mais,
a vitamina D3 otimizada não é aquelas
doses ridículas de 400 unidades que o
médico convencional receita. Estamos
falando de doses que levam os níveis
séricos para 60, 80. Eu falei de 40, 70,
mas aí tem várias interpretações
e não aqueles 30 ng por ml que o pessoal
acha tá bom. Então, nesse nível, a
vitamina D regula a função mitocondrial,
reduz progressão do câncer, melhora a
sobrevida e tem estudo mostrando isso
desde 2024. Zinco também em doses
terapêuticas não é 15 mg para prevenir
gripe, é 50 a 100 mg de zinco elementar
para restaurar a apoptose, morte celular
programada. que o câncer desliga,
reduzir atividade de células
troncocancerígenas, melhorar resposta
quimio. Um artigo de outubro de 24 da
International Society foromolecular
Medicine mostrou que o zinco suplementar
melhora dramaticamente a resposta ao
tratamento oncológico.
Segundo, suporte mitocondrial potente.
É aqui que a coisa fica realmente
interessante. Um dos conceitos mais
avançados da oncologia metabólica atual,
e tem um artigo sensacional de 24 sobre
isso é a hipótese da conexão
mitocondrial células tronco. A ideia é
que fosforilação oxidativa prejudicada
contribui pra formação de células tronco
cancerígenas que são as responsáveis por
crescimento moral, metástase e
resistência a tratamentos. E olha que
bacana, enquanto os tratamentos
convencionais atacam mutações de DNA,
mas falham em restaurar a fosforilação
oxidativa ou eliminar células
troncocancerígenas, a abordagem
integrativa faz exatamente o oposto.
Coisima ácido alfalipoico,
nac, elcarnetina. As substâncias não são
suplementos da moda, são restauradores
da função energética celular. Eles
consertam
a mitocôndria das células saudáveis para
que elas consigam competir melhor contra
o tumor. Terceiro, modulação metabólica
inteligente. Diet cetogênica bem
formulada, não é qualquer low carb da
internet, é cetogênica terapêutica com
vegetais coloridos, né, cheio de
fitonutrientes, proporção específica de
macronutrientes, monitorização de
cetonas sanguíneas para manter 05 e
quatro no sangue e fazer ajustes
individualizados.
Isso muda completamente o ambiente
metabólico. Ele reduz a glicólise,
promove a morte celular de células
cancerígenas e complementa outros
tratamentos, incluindo até o tal do dom
que eles tentaram usar anos atrás para
bloquear a glutamina, mas que causava a
toxicidade horrível quando usado de
maneira sozinha. Olha só a sacada.
Quando você combina dieta citogênica com
jejum intermitente estratégico, você não
tá simplesmente matando de fome o tumor.
Você tá criando um ambiente onde células
normais prosperam,
porque elas têm mitocôndrias funcionais
e conseguem usar centonas como
combustível. Mas as células cancerígenas
sofrem, pelo menos a maioria delas,
porque elas têm mitocôndrias defeituosas
e não consegue metabolizar acetonas de
maneira eficiente. Isso tá documentado
desde 2012 no trabalho seminal do Dr.
Thomas Cfield sobre câncer como doença
metabólica. Lembrando aqui, pessoal, que
eu já falei isso na comunidade, em
outras lives, que existem tumor sim que
conseguem metabolizar ácidos gráos, tá?
Então isso aqui funciona mais ou menos
para 80% dos tumores
e tem a desintoxicação de metais pesados
e também de desreguladores endócrinos.
Porque não adianta você tentar otimizar
metabolismo se o paciente tá intoxicado
com mercúrio, chumbo, alumínio arsênico.
Esses metais tóxicos danificam
diretamente as mitocôndrias, geram
estresse oxidativo brutal, desegulam
vias de de sinalização celular e você
tem que tirar essa carga tóxica do
organismo. Pessoal, vocês estão
acompanhando? Eu tô falando demais aqui.
Me deem aqui um feedback. O Hélio não
falou nada até agora. A Cristina Carol
comentou aqui que tinha gostado do tema
anterior, né?
Vou esperar vocês se manifestar aqui
para eu continuar.
Dra. Ana Paula, tem alguma coisa que
queira acrescentar?
Ana Paula sempre tem aí ótimas
observações.
Bem, vamos continuar aqui
o quarto aqui, ó. Assuntos complexos e
atuais. Comentar Dra. Ana Paula.
Bem, o quarto aspecto seria a
restauração sistêmica completa, né?
Então, seria o equilíbrio imunológico,
não somente aumentar a imunidade, seria
modular para que o sistema imune
reconheça e ataque células cancerígenas
sem atacar o próprio corpo. E também a
otimização hormonal, especialmente
importante, cânceres
hormôniodependentes,
que é crucial também para todo mundo que
porque hormônios regulam o metabolismo
também, inflamação e o reparo tecidual.
um alinhamento cicadiano, que é o sonho
de sono de qualidade, exposição solar
adequada,
ritmos biológicos respeitados, redução
do estresse crônico através de técnicas
comprovadas e não só relaxa aí, né? E
parece muito sim eh bastante coisa,
porque realmente uma medicina de alta
qualidade tem que ser multifatorial. O
câncer é uma doença multifatorial, então
a solução também tem que ser igual, tem
que ser multiangular.
você não vai resolver um problema
complexo com uma solução simples, né?
Então, é exatamente a armadilha que a
medicina convencional cai, achar que uma
droga que bloqueia uma via vai resolver
tudo. Isso foi um grande problema no
caso do Alzheimer.
Pau, tem um comentário aqui. Realmente
vi na prática clínica que pacientes com
vitamina C em altas doses tinham uma
ótima resposta na QT, quimioterapia e
pouquíssimos efeitos colaterais.
Doença autoimune, oncologia gatilhos.
Eu acho que o pessoal tá dormindo aqui
porque ninguém tá comentando nada.
Tô devo devo estar aborrecendo o pessoal
aqui. Bem, olha que interessante quando
você faz isso, essas medidas que eu
acabei de falar, quando você fortalece o
terreno biológico, em vez de enfraquecer
o corpo tentando matar o tumor, algo
mágico acontece. O próprio começa a
reconhecer e atacar as células
cancerígenas de forma mais eficiente. O
sistema imune volta a funcionar. A
poptose que a morte celular programada
volta a acontecer nas células que
deveriam morrer. Os mecanismos naturais
de reparo do Na volta a operar. A
autofagia, que a limpeza celular volta a
eliminar componentes defeituosos. Então
isso é uma restauração, não é uma
restrição, é uma frase que você precisa
gravar. Restauração fortalece o
hospedeiro, restrição enfraquece todo
mundo, tumor e paciente juntos. E
adivinha quem aguenta mais tempo numa
guerra de desgaste? O tumor, né,
infelizmente, porque ele tem vantagens
metabólicas que a célula normal já
perdeu. Então, deixa eu te fazer uma
pergunta. Faz sentido para você
enfraquecer um organismo que já tá
lutando contra uma doença devastadora?
Faz sentido tirar combustível essencial
de células que precisam desesperadamente
de energia para se defender? Claro que
não. Mas a indústria farmacêutica
continua insistindo nessa abordagem,
porque é isso que eles sabem fazer,
criar drogas que bloqueiem alguma coisa.
Eles não ganham dinheiro ensinando você
a se alimentar melhor, a suplementar
adequadamente, a desintoxicar o seu
corpo, a otimizar o estilo de vida. Não
dá para patentear comida de verdade. Não
dá para patentear a vitamina D do sol,
não dá para patentear jejum
intermitente, não dá também para
patentear o enzimaqued que qualquer
farmácia de manipulação ou empresa de
suplemento consegue fazer. E olha só que
conveniente quando eles perseguem essas
drogas que não funcionam. E olha que eu
trouxe aqui dados frescos de ano passado
e esse ano, mostrando os fracassos
recentes. Eles ignoram olimpicamente
décadas de evidência científica,
mostrando que abordagens nutricionais e
metabólicas realmente fazem diferença.
Tem estudo de 2024
mostrando que dieta cetogênica
melhora a resposta quimio. Tem estudo de
25 mostrando que vitamina C endovenosa
em altas doses tem múltiplos efeitos
anticâncer. Tem estudo de 24 mostrando
que otimização de vitamina D melhora
prognóstico. tem o trabalho
revolucionário sobre a hipótese
mitocondrial Células Tronco, publicado
em outubro de 24, mostrando um protocolo
híbrido de 12 semanas integrando
vitaminas, drogas reaproveitadas, dieta
e terapias adicionais que visamorar
função mitocondrial e reduzir atividades
de células tronco cancerígenas.
Mas isso não vira manchete, né? porque
não vende remédio caro. Aí fica aquela
dissonância cognitiva absurda. A
literatura científica mostra que
abordagens integrativas funcionam, mas a
prática clínica convencional ignora
completamente. E tem outro detalhe
crucial que o artigo científico de
novembro de 25 do Dr. Richard Cheng
deixou bem claro. Tumores são
heteriogêneos e metabolicamente
plásticos. Traduzindo, cada câncer é
único e cada câncer consegue se adaptar
rapidamente quando você tenta uma
estratégia única de privação. É que eu
tava falando, mesmo cortar glicose,
tumor eficiente o tempo todo. Por isso
que terapia alvo funciona por um tempo e
depois para de funcionar, o tumor muda,
ele se adapta e se
eh passa pro processo de contornar as
defesas, né? Mas quando você muda o
terreno todo, quando você melhora
simultaneamente nutrição,
desintoxicação, função imunológico,
saúde mitocondrial,
equilíbrio hormonal e reduz inflamação
sistêmica, aí o tumor não tem para onde
correr, porque você não tá atacando um
ponto, você tá mudando o ambiente
inteiro e o ambiente hostil é ambiente
hostil, não tem adaptação que dê jeito.
Isso que a gente chama na visão
integrativa de abordagem baseada em
terreno, não é matar célula, é criar
condições onde célula cancerígena não
prospera, mas célula saudável prospera.
É restaurar a miostase, é voltar ao
equilíbrio bioquímico que a natureza
projetou para funcionar. E a melhor
parte, isso não tem efeito colateral
devastador. Ninguém perde cabelo porque
tomou vitamina C da venosa. Ninguém
destrói medula óssea porque fez dieta
cetogênica. Ninguém arrebenta o sistema
imune porque suplementou com enzima Q1.
Pelo contrário, essas intervenções se
fortalecem e reparam e restauram.
Agora, isso significa abandonar o
tratamento convencional? De jeito
nenhum. Eu não tô aqui para falar para
vocês para não fazer quimio, não fazer
rádio
significa a integração, significa usar o
que a medicina convencional tem de bom
ou de melhor. E ela tem sim coisas boas,
especialmente cirurgia oncológica bem
feita, radioterapia com máquinas
avançadas, né, que não deixam radiação
se espalhar em situações específicas. e
os quimioterápicos também quando eles
são aceitáveis em termos de toxicidade,
mas sem cair na armadilha de achar que
só isso basta, sem mexer no terreno
biológico, porque décadas de evidência
mostram que só isso não basta mesmo.
Então, o futuro da oncologia não tá em
criar drogas mais potentes para bloquear
vias metabólicas especiais. O futuro tá
em entender biologia de sistemas, em
trabalhar com o corpo e não contra ele,
em restaurar função em vez de só
suprimir sintomas. tá em reconhecer que
matar o tumor não pode significar matar
o paciente junto. E olha, isso não é
teoria maluca de médico alternativo,
isso tá publicado em revistas
científicas sérias. O artigo que saiu
agora em novembro de 25 foi escrito pelo
editor chefe do Serviço de Notícias de
Medicina Ortomolecular.
É um médico com PhD treinado pelo Nage
americano, certificado de maneira
internacional. Ele é membro da Academia
Americana de Medicina Antienescimento,
na mesma academia que eu sou membro, né,
a IORM, diretor de um dos centros de
referência mundial em medicina
integrativa. Então não é charlatanice, é
ciência de ponta que a medicina
convencional quer insistir em ignorar
porque não se encaixa no modelo de
negócios deles. E tem outro ponto que
precisa ficar cristalino. Quando você
bloqueia glutamina sistemicamente,
quando você não tá só tirando o
combustível do tumor, você está
comprometendo a integridade intestinal,
o intestino passa a ficar mais
permeável, o liquigat e isso uma porta
aberta para inflamação sistêmica e
translocação bacteriana. Você tá
desarmando os seus linfócitos bem na
hora que eles mais precisam estar fortes
para atacar células cancerígenas.
está reduzindo a produção de glutationa,
que é seu principal sistema antioxidante
contra o estresse oxidativo que o
próprio câncer gera. Então isso é
literalmente contraprodutivo. Você cria
mais problemas do que resolve e aí o
paciente fica mais fraco, mais
suscetível a infecções, com menos
capacidade de tolerar outros
tratamentos, com qualidade de vida lá
embaixo e no final das contas o tomô
continua lá porque ele se adaptou, mas o
paciente não conseguiu. Essa lógica
falha. de atacar o tumor, enfraquecer o
paciente, é a mesma coisa que vemos na
outra grande epidemia do nosso século, a
demência, que é o nosso próximo assunto.
Mas antes de eu continuar,
eu queria saber se vocês querem que eu
pare agora e continue isso na próxima
live do nível dois,
ou vocês querem que continue? Porque
vocês estão muito calados aí, Hélio e
Cristina, por favor, eu só vou continuar
se vocês se manifestarem.
A gente pode deixar porque já tem uma
hora de live. Eu tava planejando fazer
duas horas de live, mas como essa é a
primeira vez, eu não sei ainda se esse
modelo de 2 horas é o melhor, se vocês
vão ficar muito cansados de me escutar
falando. E eu também preciso fazer um
treinamento de voz,
porque
eu acho que eu não aguento ficar tantas
horas falando direto, mas eu vou, eu
consigo falar mais uma hora se for o
caso. A Cristina tá dizendo aqui, por
mim continua. E o nosso amigo Hélio tá
dormindo ou tá fazendo outra coisa.
Deve est assistindo Netflix.
Não sei, pessoal, não sei porque o não
falou nada até agora aqui, né? Oli é
muito tímido. Não sei. Vamos lá, então.
Vou continuar, tá? Porque a a Cristina
falou para continuar. Olha, vou falar
uma coisa que vai te deixar arrepiado.
Você saber que hoje, nesse exato
momento, pode estar acontecendo algo
silencioso no seu cérebro que vai
determinar se você vai reconhecer seus
netos daqui a 20 anos. Acabou de sair na
literatura internacional um estudo
bombástico da Meio Clíic, é uma das
principais clínicas, na verdade é um
hospital grande, né? Não sei porque
chama Meio Clinic, que tem uma reputação
muito grande internacional. Então esse
estudo que saindo na meio clíic, ele
consegue prever com precisão assustadora
se você vai desenvolver demência anos
antes de qualquer sintoma aparecer.
Então tô falando de saber com 70 a 80%
de certeza se o seu cérebro vai dar
problema no futuro, se os dados esverem
corretos, né? E o mais louco, eles
conseguem isso medindo um marcador
específico que se acumula no seu cérebro
décadas antes de você esquecer o nome do
seu filho. Fique comigo até o final
porque eu vou te mostrar exatamente como
funciona essa ferramenta revolucionária
e mais importante o que você pode fazer
hoje para mudar essa trajetória.
Então vamos explicar mais o que tá
acontecendo. pesquisadores da Meoclinic
acabaram de publicar no Lenset
Neurology, é uma das revistas médicas
mais respeitadas do mundo, um estudo com
mais de 5.000 pessoas. Então eles
desenvolveram uma ferramenta preditiva
que combina quatro fatores principais: a
idade, o sexo. Se você carrega o gene
apo4, que é praticamente o gene maldito
do Alzheimer, e o mais importante de
todos, que é a quantidade de proteína
betamide que está se acumulando o seu
cérebro nesse momento. Então vocês todos
já ouviram falar na proteína milóide, já
falei em vários vídeos no canal
e ela é como se fosse uma sujeira
grudenta que vai se depositando entre os
neurônios. E o que descobriram? Quanto
maior a quantidade dessa proteína medida
por um exame chamado petiamiloide,
usando uma escala chamada centiloide,
maior é o risco de você estar
desenvolvendo um comprometimento
cognitivo leve ou demência no futuro. E
quando eu digo maior, eu não tô
brincando, os números são realmente
impressionantes.
Dra. Ana Paula, creio que foram assuntos
muito complexos. Mande o link. Link do
quê? Dos estudos.
Posso mandar? Mandar onde? Não, se eu
mandar no grupo. Eh, veja bem, Ana
Paula, e nós estamos aqui na no grupo
dois, né?
Em respeito a quem tá no grupo dois,
eu não posso mandar esses links lá pro
pro
WhatsApp, não, entendeu? Talvez a gente
criar um uma pasta compartilhada só com
quem é do grupo dois, né? Não sei, vou
pensar numa solução para isso.
Ã, bem, pega só esse exemplo real do
estudo, não? Ah, pô, no chat eu tenho
que fazer o levantamento aí. Não, não é,
não seria o caso fazer agora, porque eu
preciso levantar os links todos.
Pegar só esse exemplo tão real do
estudo. Um homem de 75 anos que tem o
GNA por E4, se o valor de centiloide
dele, né, esse marcador aí que usa as
quatro características for cinco, que é
relativamente baixo, o risco dele
desenvolver comprometimento cognitivo
leve durante a vida é de 56%.
Já não é pouca coisa, né?
Agora escuta aí. Se esse mesmo cara
tiver um centoide de 100, que indica
acúmulo pesado de amiloide, o risco sobe
para 76%.
É praticamente certeza que ele vai ter o
problema. E para as mulheres é pior
ainda. Uma mulher de 75 anos com o mesmo
gene, se o centoide for cinco, o risco é
de 69%.
com centóide de 100, 84% de chance de
desenvolver comprometimento cognitivo.
Quatro em cada cinco vão ter problema e
é de assustar.
O que mais me chamou atenção nesse
estudo é que eles conseguiram mostrar
algo que a gente já desconfiava, mas não
tinha prova tão robusta assim. O acúmulo
de amiloide no cérebro não é uma coisa
binária do tipo tem ou não tem, é um
contínuo, é um espectro. Então, conforme
vai aumentando a quantidade dessa
proteína, vai aumentando
proporcionalmente o risco de demência.
Não tem aquela história de, ah, passou
de tal número, está condenado, não. Cada
pontinho a mais que sobe no centoide
aumenta o seu risco. E tem mais, o
estudo mostrou que pessoas que com gene
apo e4 em qualquer nível de amiloide
sempre tem risco maior do que quem tem
do que não tem esse gene, certo? Ou
seja, a genética pesa bastante, né,
nesse centiloide aí. Mas e aqui está o
pulo do gato, mesmo quem tem o gene pode
ter níveis diferentes de amilóide.
Então você não está totalmente refém da
genética. Você pode ter nascido com as
cartas marcadas, mas ainda dá para jogar
a partida. Agora, por que que isso é tão
revolucionário? Porque até hoje a gente
trabalhava muito com risco relativo nas
pesquisas. Tipo assim, quem tem amiloide
alto tem três vezes mais risco do que
quem tem amiloide baixo.
Mas isso não responde a pergunta que o
paciente realmente quer saber, que é:
"Doutor, qual que é a minha chance de
ter aos?"
Esse estudo responde exatamente isso.
Ele dá o risco absoluto, o risco de
vida, a probabilidade real desenvolver a
doença. O Christopher Weber, que é o
diretor sênior de ciências da associação
de Alzheimer, falou uma coisa muito
perspicaz sobre esse estudo. Ele disse
que esse não é um exame diagnóstico.
Ninguém vai fazer esse exame e sair com
carimbo de vai ter Alzheimer. O que ele
quis dizer? O que isso faz é dar
informação valiosa para você e seu
médico decidirem juntos quais
intervenções valem a pena. E olha, isso
vai ser cada vez mais importante porque
estão saindo medicamentos novos, né? O
caso Lecanemabanemab,
que são aí os os sucessores do
aducanumab e eles removem a miloide do
cérebro. Não são remédios assim que são
uma maravilha, não, e são bem caros.
Então, esses remédios têm sido aprovados
para quem já tem sintomas leves, apesar
da toxicidade deles. Mas e se começarmos
a usar em quem ainda não tem sintoma
nenhum, mas já tenha amiloide alto,
talvez pessoas mais saudáveis, talvez
nesse grupo aí faça sentido usar esses
remédios. Agora vem a parte que eu
preciso te alertar.
O estudo foi feito com uma população 98%
branca, relativamente saudável e bem
educada. É o beful people, né? Isso
limita um pouco a generalização dos
resultados.
Então, a gente precisa de mais estudos
em populações diversas, em pessoas com
diferentes condições socioeconômicas e
etnias diferentes, mas isso não invalida
os achados, pelo contrário, abre caminho
para pesquisas futuras mais inclusivas.
E olha o timing disso tudo.
Recentemente, em 2024, saíram
recomendações de um painel de
especialistas globais em demência,
dizendo que o valor de cintiloide entre
24 e 30 seria um limear prático para
iniciar terapias antiamiloide em
pacientes com comprometimento cognitivo
leve ou demência leve. Ou seja, não
precisa esperar estar com centide 100. a
partir de 25 já dá para considerar
intervir. Talvez uma dose mais baixa aí
dos eh anticorpos monocolonais para ter
menos toxicidade, né?
Mas essa parte já é considerações
minhas, tá? Mas aqui está o ponto que eu
mais quero enfatizar.
A visão funcional, a abordagem
integrativa que a gente trabalha não
fica esperando passivamente você chegar
nos 25 de centilo para fazer alguma
coisa. a gente faz coisas muito antes,
né? A gente age muito antes. A prevenção
da demência não começa quando você já
tem a proteína acumulada, começa décadas
antes. O que a literatura internacional
mais recente de 2024 e 2025 está
mostrando de forma cada vez mais robusta
que demência é uma doença multifatorial.
Isso foi falado já há muitos anos pelo
Dr. Dale Bradsen.
Não existe uma causa única, não é só
Miloide, não é só genética, é uma
combinação de fatores ao longo da vida
inteira. O relatório de 2024 da Comissão
Lenet sobre demência, que é tipo a
Bíblia da prevenção de demência,
identificou 14 fatores de riscos
modificáveis. Já o Dr. Dale Bradson
identificou 36. Então, deixa eu listar
alguns aqui. Baixa educação na infância,
perda auditiva, hipertensão arterial,
obesidade, tabagismo, depressão,
inatividade física, diabetes, consumo
excessivo de álcool, traumatismo
craniano, poluição do ar, isolamento
social, problemas de visão e colesterol
alto. Isso tudo tá dentro do protocolo
recode e mais coisas ainda, né? E sabe o
que que é mais empolgante? Estudos
recentes mostraram que tratar
adequadamente alguma dessas condições
pode desacelerar
o declínio cognitivo, mesmo em quem já
tem demência. Por exemplo, um estudo
alemão de 2025 mostrou
que o uso adequado de medicação
antidiabética
estava associado a um declínio cognitivo
mais lento em pessoas com demência.
Então, o tratamento adequado de
problemas de visão também mostrou
benefícios.
Uma metiformina, né, a droga antiga para
diabetes,
muito conhecida, né, ou grifage, tem
evidências antivelescimento e também tem
evidências crescentes de efeito
neuroprotetor. Tanto que está sendo
testado em um grande estudo de prevenção
de demência combinado com intervenções
de estilo de vida. Mas não é só sobre
remedinho, não. A base de tudo é o
estilo de vida. E aqui eu não estou
falando de uma coisa só. Não adianta
você comer direitinho, mas ser
sedentário. Não adianta você exercitar,
mas dormir mal. Tem que ser uma
abordagem multifacetada, atacando vários
frontes ao mesmo tempo. Exercício físico
regular, especialmente aeróbico e
musculação em associação.
O aeróbico vai melhorar a capacidade
cárdies
e efeito neuroprotetor.
A atividade física também de força, né?
Exercício de resistência vai aumentar
aisina, que é um hormônio protetor.
Então, a atividade física aumenta o
fluxo sanguíneo cerebral, reduz a
inflamação, melhora a neuroplastidade e
olha que não precisa virar maratonista.
Nem recomendo, tá? Eu acho que a gente
cavalo basta correr no máximo 10 km, tá?
Caminhada vigorosa já faz muita
diferença.
O negócio é fazer os exercícios com
consistência. Alimentação é outro pilar
fundamental, obviamente as dietas que tm
mais evidência científica para a saúde
cerebral, pelo menos na visão
convencional, são as dietas mediterrânea
e a dieta Mind, mas eu defendo
particularmente a dieta ketoflex, que
também é uma dieta rica em vegetais
coloridos. Então, a dieta Mind, ela é
basicamente uma versão da dieta
mediterrânea focada em cérebro, mas na
abordagem funcional a gente vai além,
como eu falei na dieta ketoflex, que eu
sigo e muitos outros profissionais estão
também seguindo o protocolo Ketoflex,
que é uma dieta rica em plantauras boas,
baixa, baixíssima, né, em carboidratos
processados, com um jejum de 12 a 16
horas por dia, né? né? Então isso é
muito importante e parando de comer pelo
menos 3 horas antes de dormir. Isso
promove a tal da autofagia, que eu falei
várias vezes aqui durante a
apresentação, que é a faxina celular,
que é a questão da célula tá comendo as
próprias organelas velhas ou as células
velhas serem destruídas. Isso melhora a
função mitocondrial.
E tem a questão do sono. Dormir bem não
é luxo, é uma necessidade biológica.
Durante o sono profundo acontece a
limpeza do cérebro pelo sistema
glinfático. Então esse sistema funciona
muito melhor quando você tá dormindo. Se
você não dorme, acumula sujeira no seu
cérebro. Então o sistema linfático
quando você está dormindo remove toxinas
do cérebro, remove o amiloide. Então, se
você não dorme direito, você não tá
sabendo limpar o seu cérebro, tá
acumulando lixo. Estimulação cognitiva
também muito importante,
aprender coisas novas, ler, fazer
palavra cruzada, jogar, tocar
instrumento musical, aprender línguas. É
muito importante. Tudo isso cria o que a
gente chama de reserva cognitiva. É como
se você tivesse armazenando
inteligência para gastar quando fosse
necessário.
É tipo um backup do cérebro. Se uma área
falhar, outra pode compensar. Conexões
sociais são outro fator protetor muito
importante que são pouco falados.
Isolamento social que aconteceu muito na
pandemia, tá associado a risco maior de
demência. Então é muito importante
manter amizades saudáveis, participar de
grupos, ter vida social, não de cachaça,
né? Vida social saudável, ativa, não é
frescura, é proteção cerebral. E eu não
posso deixar de falar também sobre
suplementação estratégica. Existem
nutrientes específicos que têm evidência
de benefício paraa função cognitiva, né?
Isso que é o protocolo de suplementação
do recod. Deixa eu ligar o ar
condicionado um pouquinho aqui, pessoal.
Estamos falando aqui de ômega-3, né? é
rico em DHA, vitaminas do complexo B,
especialmente B12 folato, vitamina D de
dado, magnésio, polifenóis, como que tem
no chá verde, no cacau. Mas atenção, a
suplementação não substitui alimentação
adequada, ela é complemento e não é
base.
Controle de inflamação crônica é muito
importante. Então, a inflamação
sistêmica de baixo grau, como nós
sabemos, está ligado à neurodegeneração.
De onde vem essa inflamação? da
obesidade, da dieta rica em
ultraprocessados, inflamatória,
dieta rica em açúcar, o sedentarismo, a
disbiose intestinal, o estresse crônico
e o sono ruim. Tudo isso se conecta. Tem
a questão das toxinas ambientais,
exposição crônica, metais pesados, que
eu já falei do outro assunto, né?
Alumínio, chumbo, mercúrio, exposição a
pesticidas, poluição do ar, tudo isso
aumenta o risco de demência.
Então, a gente precisa tanto evitar a
exposição quanto otimizar o sistema de
detox do organismo. Agora, deixa eu te
contar o que que diferencia a abordagem
funcional da abordagem convencional. A
medicina tradicional ou ortodoxa
geralmente espera você ter sintomas para
tratar, né, para agir. Você esqueceu
onde colocou a chave, normal é da idade,
deixa para lá. Esqueceu o nome de um
conhecido, ah, acontece. Só quando já tá
com teste significativo é que pensam
investigar. E aí quando investigam
geralmente é só para confirmar o
diagnóstico e oferecer um remédio que na
maior ou na melhor das hipóteses vai
desacelerar a progressão só um
pouquinho, né? Vai deixar a o problema
praticamente igual, só vai desacelerar a
evolução do problema.
Então, a visão funcional trabalha
diferente. A gente quer saber por o
cérebro dessa pessoa tá falhando, tá
inflamado, tem resistência insulina, tem
deficiência de nutrientes, tem
toxicidade, tem problema hormonal, tem
infecções crônicas, tem problema
vascular, tem, por exemplo, apneia do
sono, tem foco dentário, né? A gente
investiga as causas raízes e trata elas
de forma personalizada.
E olha, tem casos impressionantes,
pessoas que reverteram o declírio
incognitivo com essa abordagem. Eu não
estou falando de casos avançados de
Alzheimer com perda neuronal massiva.
Esses são os mais difíceis de tratar.
Mais pessoas com comprometimento
inicial, cognitivo, cognitivo leve,
queixos subjetivos de memória, tem
estudos de caso mostrando melhora
significativa com os protocolos
multimodais, como é o caso do protocolo
recode, Dr. Dale Braden, que eu fiz o
curso duas vezes com ele, ele é o
pioneiro, né, ou num dos pioneiros
nisso. Tem vários relatos de casos com
melhor objetiva em teste cognitivo.
Claro que precisa de mais pesquisa, mais
estudos controlados. Mas os resultados
preliminares são muito animadores e o
mais importante são intervenções
seguras. Não tem risco de você piorar
comendo melhor, fazendo atividade
física, dormindo direito, controlando
estresse, suplementando e fazendo eh
treinamento cerebral, né, ou fazendo
jejum. Então, voltando ao estudo da meio
clínica que estamos falando, o exame de
petamiloide com quantificação sem
tiloide
é uma ferramenta fantástica para
estratar risco. Eu mesmo vou fazer esse
exame quando tiver disponível eh no
Brasil, talvez até viaje para lá para
fazer. Se você fizer e descobrir que tem
centó de 50, 60, você sabe que está em
risco alto. Mas a pergunta que fica é: e
daí o que que você vai fazer com essa
nova informação? Pular da ponte? Não,
pessoal.
Na medicina convencional, as opções são
limitadas, obviamente você pode entrar
num protocolo com um desses anticorpos
monoclonais que eu falo que é é meio
tóxico, meio não, bastante tóxico, mas
talvez a gente possa criar aí protocolos
com doses menores paraa prevenção, como
eu falei, o aducanumab, o Lecanemab e o
donanemab,
em que esses medicamentos podem remover
o amilóide do cérebro e tem evidência de
que desaceleram um pouco a progressão,
mas tem efeitos colaterais. tem edema
cerebral, sangramento em 10% dos casos
são caros e o benefício também é
modesto. Então, alguns pacientes, como
eu falei, tem edema microomorragia.
Então, já na abordagem integrativa, a
informação de que você tem milide alto é
um gatilho para uma intervenção
agressiva, multifacetada, estilo de
vida, nutrição, suplementação, controle
de fatores de risco, é uma oportunidade
de ouro para prevenir que aquele
amilóide continue acumulando, que os
sintomas apareçam. E tem uma coisa
importante que eu preciso falar. O exame
de petilóde ainda é bastante caro, não é
muito disponível, não é amplamente
disponível. No Brasil o acesso é bem
limitado, mas estão desenvolvendo
marcadores sanguíneos de amilóde, né?
Alguns estão disponíveis até no fleur
aí, que prometem ser muito mais
acessíveis. Já tem testes em sangue que
detectam a proteína milóide com boa
curácia. Então, nos próximos anos vai se
tornar mais popular, mais comum. Mais
honestamente, você não precisa esperar
ter um exame de amilóide para começar a
cuidar do seu cérebro. Eu já faço isso
há anos por causa do meu histórico
familiar de quatro parentes com a doença
de Alzheimer. Então, se você tem mais de
40, como é o meu caso, que tenho 50, se
tem histórico familiar de demência, o
meu caso, você tem fatores de risco, aí
eu não tenho, não tenho diabetes, não
tenho hipertensão,
não tenho obesidade, não tenho
sedentarismo, mas mesmo assim você já
sabe que precisa agir, né? Não espera
aparecer o sintoma, não espera esquecer
o nome do neto. Eu não tenho netos
ainda, vai demorar para ter para poder
começar a fazer isso daí, né?
Então, precisa começar hoje. Você pode
começar decidindo trocar o refrigerante
por água, pode decidir subir de escada
em vez de elevador. Pode-se de pode-se
de dormir meia hora mais cedo, pode-se
de ligar para aquele amigo que você não
vê faz tempo. São pequenas escolhas que
acumuladas ao longo de anos fazem uma
tremenda diferença. E outra coisa,
quatro pessoas na minha família, como eu
já falei, tiveram Alzheimer. Eu tenho um
histórico pesado, então isso para mim
não é teoria, isso para mim é muito
importante, é pessoal. Então eu aplico
em mim tudo isso que eu acabei de falar
para vocês. Eu monitoro meus
biomarcadores, eu cuido da minha
alimentação, do meu sono, do meu
exercício, da minha suplementação,
porque eu sei que genética não é
destino, é predisposição e predisposição
pode ser modulada. Então eu vou resumir
aqui o que você precisa levar desse
vídeo. Primeiro, existe agora uma
ferramenta preditiva poderosa que
consegue estimar seu risco de demência
anos antes dos sintomas, baseado em
quanto amiloide você tem acumular no
cérebro. Segundo, quanto mais amiloide,
maior risco. E se tiver o gene APO E4,
piora mais ainda esse risco. Terceiro,
mas você também não é refém disso.
Demência é multifatorial e você pode
mexer em vários fatores. Quarto, a
prevenção precisa começar cedo, décadas
antes dos sintomas. Quinto, a abordagem
mais eficaz é multifacetada, atacando
vários frontes, dieta, exercício, sono,
suplementação, controle de fatores de
risco, redução de toxinas, estimulação
cognitiva e conexões sociais. Isso não é
fácil. Mudar o estilo de vida de verdade
dá muito trabalho. Existe disciplina,
consistência. Tem dia que você vai
querer vacilar, vai querer pular a
cerca. Tem dia que você vai comer
porcaria, né? O dia do lixo, vai pular o
treino, vai dormir tarde e isso tá tudo
bem. Você falhar de vez em quando é
aceitável. O importante é a tendência
geral. É o que faz na maior parte do
tempo, porque perfeição não existe. O
que existe é progresso consistente.
Percebem o padrão? Nós estamos
perseguindo placas amilóides na
demência. Estamos perseguindo a
glutamina no câncer.
Estamos ignorando a inflamação de novas
tecnologias.
Estamos enterrando estudos sobre
nutrientes essenciais por causa de
obsessão pro RCT. O que que liga tudo
isso? Qual que é a causa raiz que o
sistema convencional está ignorando em
todas essas doenças? A resposta é a meu
ver, o motor das células, que seria o
nosso próximo assunto, a mitocôndria.
Temos 1 hora e meia de live. Eu acho que
eu vou encerrar por aqui, tá?
Eu vou deixar falar desse assunto na
próxima.
Bem, o Hélio acho que ele não tá
participando da live. Ele aparece para
mim como novo membro, mas não sei o que
aconteceu. A Cristina disse que eu podia
continuar, mas eu acho que eu já
entreguei muita informação condensada.
Eu preciso que vocês primeiro reflitam
sobre isso. O vídeo vai ficar gravado e
na parte, né, fechada do canal para quem
é nível dois. Aí depois eu vou soltar
algumas pérolas desse vídeo nas redes
sociais para divulgar o material que nós
conversamos aqui. Pessoal, muito
obrigado pela participação de vocês e
daqui a duas semanas teremos uma nova
live, tá bom? Eh, Cristina, se você
tiver escutando, por favor, me diga se
domingo para você à noite é um bom dia,
tá?
Eu acho que domingo à noite é um bom
horário, mas talvez vocês não queiram.
Então, a nossa próxima live
vai ser dia
30, tá? 30 de novembro. Eu vou viajar
para Portugal dia 2.
Não sei como é que vai ficar as lives
depois lá, mas eh então, dia 30 nós
vamos ter a nossa segunda live do grupo
dois,
do grupo dos estudos avançados.
Isso, Cristina, revê a live com calma,
conversa lá no grupo o que que você
achou da live, divulga lá no grupo do
WhatsApp o que que você achou e a gente
vai então fazer a próxima live, dia 30.
A Maria Mendes parece que acaba de
entrar. Maria Mendes, você tá ao vivo
mesmo ou você só me aparece para mim
porque você se tornou membro? Pode ser
que apareceu para mim aqui só porque é
novo membro, né?
Bem,
ah, Estela Mares ou aparecer, dona
Estela, dona Estela.
Tava muito cedo para você a live,
Estela.
Você vai ter que assistir depois a live,
viu? Porque eu tô encerrando aqui.
Estela, horário para você é ruim? 19
horas de domingo.
Ah, é ótimo. Mas qual que é o horário
que você acha melhor para você? Porque
você entrou agora às 8:30, né?
Eu
acho que Estela Mares se afastou das
nossas lives semanais porque tava meio
de saco cheio de perguntas no Não sei se
foi isso, tá?
Não sei se foi isso,
porque eu senti sua falta, viu Estela,
lá da do grupo.
Eh, eu entendi que talvez você tenha
ficado irritada com alguns membros que
fazem umas perguntas meio
com problemáticas, né? Não sei se foi
isso,
mas eu preciso respeitar o pessoal lá,
né? Então eu vou continuar respeitando
da melhor forma possível e respondendo
as perguntas.
Meu pai tá ligando aqui. Só só um
instantinho, pessoal.
Oi, pai. Tudo bem?
Tá bom, pai. Obrigada a você.
Tá se recuperando, graças a Deus.
Sim, sim. É, foi sério. Mas
beijo, pai. É com Deus.
Ô meu Deus, Estela, a tua tia faleceu.
Foi?
É aquela tua tia lá do que tava lá na
casa de repouso aqui do Alto da Lapa. É
a mesma.
Ô meu Deus, Estela Mares, tá doente. O
que que a sua mãe tem?
Quer dizer, se você quiser falar aqui,
né, se não não puder falar, não tem
problema não, tá?
Meus sentimentos, tá? Pelo falecimento
da sua tia Estela.
Então, ela falou que às 19 horas tá
ótimo o horário, né? Então vamos manter
esse horário então das 19 horas, né?
Então, repetindo, dia 30 nós vamos fazer
a segunda live
e aí eu vou
continuar esses assuntos de hoje, tá?
Então, Estela, se você se você
puder ou quiser, tá, assiste o vídeo
gravado que vai ficar na comunidade
fechada, tá bom, pessoal?
Ah, tu também tá com pressão alta. Hum.
Não, e não tá conseguindo controlar
direito.
Bem, pessoal, eh obrigado pela presença
de vocês e a gente se vê ou na live da
terça-feira agora das das respostas das
perguntas ou na próxima
no próximo dia 30, domingo.
É, sua tia agora está livre da demência
do câncer porque ela está descansando em
paz, graças a Deus, né?
Bem, pessoal, abraço, até a próxima.